the pretty woman's favorite who stars in
the title role of Sommersby Richard Gere
I want to say hello to my friends up in
Vancouver right now we're doing an
intersection up there hi guys I'll see
you later tonight I had a thought about
something actually before I commit I
want to share everything it's going to
be short but I was really struck by this
idea that there were 1 billion people
watching this thing it's astonishing 1
billion people watching I was curious
about what countries this was actually
going to and and it is in fact being
seen in China right now and the first
thought that came to me was I wonder if
Deng Xiaoping is actually watching this
right now with his children and his
grandchildren and with the knowledge
that that that would a horrendous
horrendous human rights situation there
is in China not only towards our own
people but to Tibet as well and I was
when it was this kind of if something
miraculous the really kind of movie like
could happen here where we could all
kind of send love and and truth a kind
of sanity to Deng Xiaoping right now in
Beijing that he will take his troops and
take the Chinese away from Tibet and
allow these people to live as free
independent people again so
but we send this thoughts and this
thought out send this thought anyhow our
Direction demands taste talent and the
diplomacy to convince producers that
they also have tastes and talent now
five very very different imaginative
examples of their work are these
nominees for best achievement in art
direction Bram Stoker's Dracula art
direction by Thomas Sanders set
decoration by Garrett Lewis
art direction by Stuart Craig set
decoration by Chris a Butler
Howards End art direction by Luciana our
Iggy set decoration by Ian Whitaker
toys art direction by ferdinando
scarfiotti my dear friend a set
decoration by Linda de Sena Unforgiven
our direction by Henri Bumstead set
decoration by Janice blackie go Dean and
the Oscar goes to Luciana or Iggy for
Howards End set the duration
Ian Whitaker
the enforcer in his message in how it
send said only connect and I feel that
was very much the case behind the scenes
in Howards End as in front of the camera
because for me it was a very special
film as I was welcomed into the family
of Ismail merchant and Jim ivory and I
would very much like to pay a great
tribute to them because in Ismail we
found a constructive and enthusiastic
and encouraging producer and in Jim a
charismatic and meticulous director who
believes in the visual importance of the
film and who Brooks no compromise and
I'm very deeply honored to have this
award in this year of honoring women in
movies especially in my capacity
andie macdowell Whoopi Goldberg and fun
with Jon Lovitz next on Academy Awards
nine